[Musique]
il ya du monde
vas-y on va bouger
[Musique]
on va aller faire un petit tunnel on va
graff est comme ça nous arrive de le
faire assez souvent
géographe avec des amis à moi la plupart
je les connais depuis un petit bout de
temps maintenant
les graphes avec les rt z quand on va à
graffer on prend des sprays et le plus
important c'est la petite veste ratp
franchement c'est vraiment pour le pour
le délire d'avoir un vêtement ratp
surnommé ya pas plus de protection que
ça en voilà on bouge parce qu'il ya des
travailleurs qui bossent sur les voies
donc on va pas tenter le diable
on va aller à sur l'a5 sûr
des voix qui sont un peu plus calme je
pense qu'on va pouvoir pouvoir essayer
de rentrer par l'autre porte à porte et
un peu plus loin au gros là il est 3
heures 35
on va essayer de rentrer dans le sur les
voies et non moi je pense que ça peut
être là ça peut être jouable
je pense que ça va le faire les frères
c'est brice et brooklyn le graff ya je
dirais que tu as honnêtement 70% du
temps où tu vas faire que que regarder
si elles la sécu s'il ya des métros
aussi l'accès possible et les 30% du
temps ça va être
c'est là où tu vas t'amuser le plus en
fait ça va être que de la peinture mais
tu auras pas les 30% sans les 70% de
surveillance à voir
ah j'y étais déjà offert mon
sport ouais
well et un pétain la lumière tata la
lumière tu as ta lumière d'un tana de
méru
[Musique]
ouais fait bellac au troisième rang
ouais c'est grand c'est cela la les deux
les deux grands là c'est le rail
électrique à cela tu évites de toucher
si tu veux rester en vie les gars pour
le rtl on peut faire du à elle jusqu'au
strike ça vous va ou pas jusqu'au
stracke jusqu'aux os du strike
l'atmosphère en gros c'est que tout le
monde sait à peu près ce qu'il a à faire
c'est ça qui est bien tu vois pas
terrien quant à une équipe que tu
connais depuis un petit bout de temps
[Musique]
et quichotte eu mais juste les secrets
dans le ton sac au cas où fire partir en
deux quand tu grave dans le métro dans
une démarche que t'as pas forcément dans
les autres endroits en fait et c'est ça
qui va donner un peu plus de un peu plus
de crédibilité par rapport aux autres et
respecter les gens voient ton grave quoi
qu'il arrive et c'est vrai que c'est une
excellente pub en fait en soi
high tech
[Musique]
il y avait sûrement un gars de la sécu
qui était au bout du tunnel
et du coup là on va juste posé deux
minutes et on va voir ce qui se passe
pas du show la tuque où il est un peu
s'il n'a pas d'ego va de la stp ben un
peu partout qui circulent qui ça vient
pas quoi j'ai pu parler avec quelques
anciens qui m'ont dit que c'était un peu
plus facile parce qu'à leur poids qui
avait pas autant de caméras de
technologie pour surveiller que ce soit
des pots ou autre j'ai fait la
comparaison avec les publicités dans le
métro reçoit les publicités dans le
métro personne te demande ton avis on ne
demande pas si tu veux voir la publicité
winamax ou la publicité de la fdj tu
vois on demande pas la vie des gens mais
on est là on attend qu'ils regardent et
en soit ça nous fait aussi plaisir que
les gens voient voilée grave qu on a
fait surtout qu'il y en a certains pour
y en a beaucoup en vrai qui trouve ça
quand même assez joli aussi